So, you can actually cause the
phase behavior of a material
to change by changing a pressure.
Now, what is pressure?
Pressure, of course, is
the effect of the gas
that is around us, that is
squeezing on ourselves all the time.
We get so used to it,
we don't even feel it.
But actually, the pressure of
the air around us is pretty high.
It's called 1 atmosphere of
pressure, and it's essentially
a force that's squeezing
on us all the time,
that our bodies are squeezing out at.
Now, you know from either
experience, or not,
that if you climb a very high mountain,
the amount of air that is around you
decreases.
So, let me show you what
the phase behavior of water
looks like as a function of pressure.
So, here's the phase diagram
that I showed you before.
At zero degrees Celsius,
water transitions
from a liquid to a solid, and
at 100 degrees Celsius, water
transitions from a liquid to a gas.
If we increase the pressure to
about 1 and 1/2 atmospheres,
then it turns out that the
solid-liquid transition still
occurs at around zero degrees
Celsius; it doesn't change very much.
But the liquid-gas transition
occurs at a higher temperature--
it's at about 112 degrees Celsius.
Whereas, in turn, if we
lower the pressure-- so,
if we went down to about, say,
3/4 of an atmosphere-- then,
again, the liquid-solid
temperature stays about the same,
but the liquid-gas transition
temperature decreases to about 92
degrees Celsius.
Scientists like to organize this in
what we call a two-dimensional phase
diagram.
So, this is a phase diagram where on
the x-axis, we have the temperature,
and on the y-axis, we have the pressure.
And what we do is we label the locus
of points where the material changes
from a solid, to a liquid, to a gas, by
simply connecting the dots of the lines
that we've just drawn before.
And this is something that
we call a phase diagram.
So this is a two-dimensional
phase diagram.
And you see in this
phase diagram that there
is a region-- there's a big region
where the material is solid,
there's another region where
the material is a liquid,
and there's a third region
where the material is a gas.
At any point that you
are on the phase diagram,
you can always find out what
the behavior of the material is.
So, at 1 atmosphere, and
about 23 degrees Celsius,
you can read off this plot
that water is a liquid.
But this allows you to generalize
it to many other conditions.
And so nitrogen has a phase
diagram that you'll see
looks a lot like that of water.
There is a solid phase, a
liquid phase, and a gas phase.
At low enough pressures,
actually, nitrogen also
has a situation where the solid
phase transitions directly to a gas
without a liquid phase.
But there's this big liquid phase
which is the part at 1 atmosphere that
gives rise to liquid nitrogen.
If we change the pressure, we can
change the phase of the liquid nitrogen
by cooling it.
I'm going to use this vacuum system.
And as it evaporates, the
heat goes off with the gas,
and the liquid that's left
behind gets colder and colder.
And at some point, we're going to
get below the melting temperature
of nitrogen, and hopefully
we will see solid nitrogen.
First, I'm going to turn
on the pump, and then
quickly-- So, the nitrogen is boiling
now, because the pressure over it
is lower than its vapor pressure.
It's internal heat that's
causing it to boil.
It boils, it cools, and then,
what we see is solid nitrogen.
Here is dry ice.
If we raise the pressure,
we can put the dry ice--
we can put the carbon dioxide in a
place where it can exist as a liquid.
Going to seal it up so
that the gas cannot escape.
Because the gas can't escape,
the pressure inside of the tube
is going to go up.
When the pressure inside of the
tube reaches about 5 atmospheres,
the dry ice reaches a point
where instead of going directly
to gas, subliming, it can melt. It
can turn from a solid to a liquid.
Now, what's going on
right now is heat going
into the tube is causing
the dry ice to sublime.
As the gas builds up inside of
the tube, the pressure goes up.
And as the pressure goes up-- there
it goes-- the dry ice now can melt.
And we have mostly liquid.
And if I release the pressure,
the liquid carbon dioxide
can no longer exist as a liquid.
And because it's still cold, it
condenses straight back into a solid.